Speaker 1: You have to watch.
We wonder why things happen.
And then we see right wing media and then
we realize why.
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson went
on a rant last night in which he minimized
what happened on January six, the day of the
Trump riots, of course.
Speaker 2: But he also says in many ways
Speaker 1: the rioters were correct.
They were correct in why they were there.
Speaker 2: But the reasons he gives
Speaker 1: for why the rioters
Speaker 2: were correct are reasons
Speaker 1: none of the rioters actually knew
about when they rioted on January six.
I'm getting ahead of myself, and we're going
to get to that in a second.
This is so upside down and backwards it really
requires almost like trapeze artist contortion
ism
Speaker 2: to under two to even explain
Speaker 1: what Tucker is doing.
So let's see what Tucker says, and then we
will talk about it.
Speaker 6: What was January 6th?
Well, there was destruction of property which
were totally opposed to.
But what motivated it?
Why religious people there?
Well, for the most part, a year later, it's
very clear January 6th was essentially what
it appeared to be.
Thousands of ordinary American citizens, voters,
people who believe in our democracy far more
fervently than Liz Cheney ever has came to
Washington because they sincerely believed
democracy had been thwarted.
They believe the presidential election was
unfair, and they have a right to believe that.
And by the way, in many ways they were correct.
The presidential election was unfair, and
you don't have to do anything about voting
machines to believe that.
Consider the facts that we know.
As Election Day approached, Verizon, T-Mobile
and AT&T shut down the Trump campaign's ability
to send text messages and then Google, this
has never even been reported.
But it is widely known Google prevented the
Trump campaign from raising money over Gmail.
There's no precedent for that.
The Trump reelection campaign lost millions
in donation.
That was the whole point of it.
So the most powerful companies on planet Earth,
heavily regulated by the government benefiting
from government contracts, swung behind Joe
Biden and tried to stop Donald Trump, the
sitting president, in his tracks.
Is that fair?
Speaker 1: OK, so let's let's talk.
Each piece of that through.
They were regular people who thought democracy
had been thwarted and since they believed
democracy had been thwarted, they were right
to be there.
Understand that this isn't like self-defense.
If you sincerely thought your life was at
risk, you were able to legally use any force
necessary.
If even if your life wasn't actually in danger,
if you believed it.
The fact that they
Speaker 2: fell
Speaker 1: for a conspiracy theories about
the election and traveled to D.C. and followed
Trump's
Speaker 2: directions and went to the
Speaker 1: Capitol and did all the stuff that
doesn't make them innocent
Speaker 2: because they believed the election
had been stolen because
Speaker 1: this wouldn't even be the way to
handle it if that were true.
Now then, Tucker slips in a
Speaker 2: pretty, pretty slick move, which
is, he says,
Speaker 1: they have a right to
Speaker 2: believe that that's a linguistic
trick.
Speaker 1: No one's denying that the writers
have a right to believe the election was stolen.
They have a right to believe Joe Biden died
10 years ago, and it's an electronic cyborg
replacement.
They have a right to believe whatever they
want.
They're not being charged for what they believe.
Believing isn't a crime here.
The charges are for the laws that they broke,
so that's a red herring that Tucker throws
in.
But then the meat of this segment is Tucker
introducing totally different reasoning for
how they were correct.
And what do you mean they were correct?
Speaker 2: Well, Verizon,
Speaker 1: T-Mobile and AT&T shut down Trump's
texting.
Tucker says Google prevented Trump from raising
money over Gmail.
These items were not a factor in the riders
being there.
They weren't being discussed at the time.
This is a post facto rationalization that
Tucker has come up with, but more importantly,
are those claims even true?
And the answer is no.
Unsolicited campaign texts to people who have
opted into them are legally dubious.
It's a murky area because
Speaker 2: sometimes campaigns will say, Well,
we have voter
Speaker 1: registration data, they've registered
to vote, and so they are people that are valid
for us to target, whereas others say, No,
no, no, they haven't opted into your communications.
You can't text them.
And what happened the
Speaker 2: summer
Speaker 1: before the election was that the
Trump campaign
Speaker 2: was clashing with
Speaker 1: AT&T, Verizon and T-Mobile.
Third party screening tools were flagging
Trump's unsolicited text to people as spam.
Trump's campaign was arguing We can send these.
We are being silenced.
T-Mobile, AT&T and Verizon are saying unsolicited
mass texts aren't allowed, and we have third
party tools
Speaker 2: in place to detect that
Speaker 1: it was a murky legal area.
And the idea that this was Trump's campaign
being silenced is just completely wrong.
Lastly, Tucker said Google prevented
Speaker 2: Trump from raising
Speaker 1: money over
Speaker 2: Gmail.
I couldn't even
Speaker 1: find information on that.
The closest thing I found is that at the peak
of the campaign, some of you who were on these
lists might remember the Trump campaign was
sending out fundraising emails every 90 or
120 minutes.
Speaker 2: Eric Jr. Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: I'm sorry, Eric.
Don Jr., Trump.
We need your money.
They appear to have started getting caught
in Gmail spam filters.
Speaker 2: That's what happened.
And because of
Speaker 1: their frequency, they were going
to spam and
Speaker 2: being blocked on that basis.
Speaker 1: Maybe there is more to that, but
I have found no evidence at all that Gmail
Speaker 2: blocked Trump from raising money.
It seems they
Speaker 1: were sending such a high rate of
email that it started triggering the spam
filters on
Speaker 2: Gmail.
So not only is
Speaker 1: Tucker
Speaker 2: wrong in that these weren't the
Speaker 1: reasons the writers were there.
Tucker is wrong that these things
Speaker 2: even took place.
Speaker 1: Lie upon distortion, upon deception,
upon lie.